So we want to understand the relationship between Identifier or variable names
(this means the same thing) and storage places,
particular values as we're running our program; the state of the world.
If I write something like this in Javascript, it's going to return 2.
Conceptually, somewhere there's a box where we've made enough room
to store the value 2, and we've labeled that with x.
Since this is a place for storing a value, we might call it a storage location or storage place.
If I write x=3, we need to go back to this box and update it with the new value,
because x can only have 1 value at a time in the same context.
So, if I declare another variable, it's going to make another box, another storage location.
We'll need to use more memory in the computer to store this value.
Let's see a more complete example.
Here in this program we start off by initializing y to 2,
we declare a myfun function of x, it prints out x and then it prints out y,
and then we call a myfun of y plus 5.
A little reasoning suggests that this is going to print out first the value of x,
x is y plus 5, y is 2, so first we're going to print out 7,
and then we're going to print out y which was 2, 7 and 2.
So, initially maybe our world looks a bit like this.
Y has the value of 2. But then when we call this function,
we're moving into a slightly new context
that has to have room for x, it's actual argument.
The particular value we put in there is y plus 5, or 7, but we want to remember our roots.
I defined this function here right next to the place where y was equal to 2,
so when I'm in this context, printing out x and y,
I can get the value of x right here, and I may have to look a little farther to get the value of y,
but I can just trace the arrows and do it.
Whenever we make a function call, it's going to get us a new box, new storage locations,
and I'm going to firm up this intuition in just a bit.
I realize it's very hand-wavy now.
Here's the quiz. I've written a Python program that has 3 print statements.
I'd like you to tell me what each one prints out. Fill in the blanks.